we have
benjamin
who is a 12 year old who has made over
400 000 in nfts coming on the podcast
right now on the show and it's not a
podcast on the show uh i think that we
can just pull them up right now versus
go right through it no commercials know
anything benjamin what's up man
hello how are you
i'm doing baha'i i'm doing great where
where are you uh geography-wise what
city do you live in
i'm currently in london uk amazing all
right you're 12 years old right
yes man i wish i was still 12. that's a
fun time to be alive all right
how did you first come across
bitcoin cryptocurrencies nfts etc
so i got interested in mfts earlier this
year my dad's friend who's been in
bitcoin for a very long time bought a
rare pepe which is one of the few nft
collections on the bitcoin network for
27 000
and i instantly became fascinated that
someone was willing to spend
this much money on a jpeg so i did some
research into mft
dude legend all right when you started
looking at the nfts why were you so
interested you saw your friends uh your
dad's friend buy it for a lot of money
and you obviously were probably laughing
like why are you buying a jpeg for tens
of thousands of dollars but why were you
interested in it
in every industry the digital format has
massively outperformed the analog format
i don't think of entities as artwork i
don't think of them as digital artwork i
think of them as programmable digital
artwork
you are a legend you're right yes that
is exactly what this is all right so
once you decided that which by the way
there's a ton of boomers on wall street
that you need to go tell that to because
they're still confused but once you
decided that what was the first thing
that you did with nfts
so i watched a few youtube tutorials
about nfps and started work on my first
collection called minecraft and heart
because i'm a big fan of minecraft i've
been playing it for a long time and it
consisted of 40 small minecraft
characters um unfortunately i didn't
sell any of them but i gave one away on
twitter and then after that i wanted to
enter the generative space in this nfc
sector so i started work on weird world
okay so when you first started looking
at nfts the first thing that you did was
you went you did a youtube tutorial is
that where you normally learn is on
youtube rather than in school
yes
all right which tells me i always say
that youtube's better than regular
school right
uh i guess
all right when you decided that you were
gonna do this did you tell any of your
friends
oh no i kept it secret at the time all
right did you tell your dad
yeah what did your parents think when
you told them that you were gonna go
sell jpegs on the internet
well
my dad
was quite interested i have to say
so he got it right away as well
yes okay and then when you went and what
was the first one that you actually sold
i think there was about 40 of them in
the nft collection
yes in my first collection the minecraft
bihar i didn't sell any of them but i
gave one away
okay and then the second collection what
did you do
so in the second collection it was
generally automatically generated so i
fed all the traits and base layers into
an open source python script which
generated all of my 3 350 whales i then
started work on a smart contract as it's
quite easy with a smart contract you
just look at the standard smart contract
that the other nfp collection just used
and just changes variables so when it
says uh the maximum supply of tokens you
change that to your maximum supply
the hard and difficult bit which i
needed my dad to help me was when you
connected a smart contract to the
website so
that's one thing that my dad helped me
on at the end and then i then posted a
thread on twitter on how i was able to
do this and i had not that many
followers at the time but i think
another nft collection retweeted it and
the thread just blew up it went viral
people just connected with my story
because i was so young
benjamin are you gonna come on my show
and flex on me and tell everyone that
you're smarter than me that was
incredible
all right so how many nfts have you
actually sold right now
do you know what the number is
i sold all of the 3 350 on the mint and
then i think we've done over 1.6
k volume traded in east on secondary
sales okay in dollar terms how much
money have you made so far
i've made 400 000 us dollars
legend
all right your friends know about this
now
i kept it secret but when a major outlet
in the uk
wrote a story about it literally all my
friends just found out and started
making jokes i was able to buy this
school
we made the same jokes exactly oh yeah i
saw that yeah all right so what do your
friends say like when they first read
the story you're 12 years old do your
friends call you text you they come over
to your house like what like what do
they react when they find out that
you're richer than some of their parents
well they're quite shocked that i made
four hundred thousand dollars from
selling jpegs
online
all right and then when your parents
find out that you've made all this money
what do they think
well
it was just all meant to be a learning
experience i was i just expected to make
like 20 pounds from this i never
expected to make 400 thousand dollars
and neither did my parents
all right and so you got paid in eth
yes all right did you sell the eth are
you keeping it in eath are you moving it
to something else what are you doing
with what you got
uh i'm keeping it in east and i'm
hodling wow okay and when you look at
the volumes of the secondary market are
you paying attention or doing anything
with that collection or you're kind of
just letting it run now
so i'm letting it run now and then i do
some um changes to the website so i
think a few days ago i changed the
gradient on the weird whales text on the
website i just do small changes here and
then all right now here's the big
question when that article came out and
they said that you had made 400 000
selling this on the internet what did
your teachers in principle at school say
well
one of my teachers
messaged me and said that they were
surprised and couldn't wait to see me in
september when i go back to school
wow got teachers in his dna yeah
that teacher may be asking you for a job
soon
all right so can we can we uh talk to
you about an idea that we have
um yeah sure we think that you should
take twenty thousand dollars and buy the
school we think that we should buy your
school and just name it benjamin school
moving forward what do you think
that's an interesting idea i have to say
are you interested what what if we
together what if we together you put 20
000 up we put 20 000 up and we buy your
school and rename it after you what
would your teacher say then
uh
i'm not sure to donate them they
might be shocked
we for fifty thousand they may make you
the principal
all right so talk to us about what are
your plans moving forward what are you
gonna do are you gonna do another nft
drop are you gonna do something else in
the space what are you thinking now
so i don't want to be known as the weed
wealth kid for the rest of my life i
don't want to be a one-hit wonder
you are a long-term thinker okay
in the future i want to do an
infrastructure business which is where
the opportunities are at how with my
brother who's also an amazing coder
however in the meantime i'm working on
small nft collections to get some
experience okay where is uh how old is
your brother
he's one year older than me so you're 12
he's 13
yeah what do you guys eat for dinner
what are your parents feeding you why
are you guys so smart
um
well i have normal food i guess
what questions do you have from benjamin
benjamin uh thanks for doing this nice
to meet you
you're great dude you're awesome
we love you if you ever come to america
you have to come see us yeah i i can
learn a lot from you at sea
speaking of what are you learning in
school like i was looking up the other
day when we were talking about you on
the show and i made a comment like when
i looked it up it said decimals and
percentages and negative numbers
like you it seems like you know all that
so like what's happening in class are
you paying attention or are they
teaching you new things what's going on
there
um i'm paying attention
uh
yeah i have to apart from that um school
has been interesting i do not learn
coding at school most of that was mainly
taught to me by my dad at home
what do they teach you in math class
right now is it decimals and stuff
yeah it's decimals i think we did like
ants term
before we
went on break to summer holidays
man you guys do it in terms of that's
why i mean it's crazy it seems like
what you're saying is you've learned
more from youtube and at home from your
dad than you're necessarily learning in
school
that's a fair place
yeah john what questions you got john
and you are about the same age benjamin
i just kidding kidding
it's nice to meet you thank you for
coming on the show you are an absolute
legend in my mind
one i love how you're going after like
the infrastructure don't want to be one
hit wonder genius
but can you i'm just curious can you
confirm something did your weird whale
sell out in nine hours
yes
three thousand over three thousand jpegs
you sold nine hours
yes
are your friends like asking to go to
dinner and stuff like are they like
hitting you up like hey man when are we
gonna go out what's what's going on
there what are they saying uh i think
they regard me as their jpeg dealer from
now on
that's what that's your nickname in the
halls of uh
school as the jpeg dealer yeah
did you buy anything once that you made
the money did you even buy like
anything a pair of shoes anything for
yourself uh i treated with myself with a
few really cheap entities but apart from
that i'm trying to keep my money in
crypto and not spend it so you well hold
on a second back up
you made four hundred thousand dollars
worth of uh each have cryptocurrency and
you didn't take a single
piece of that money and buy anything in
the
analog world you simply bought a couple
other nfts in the digital world and
that's it
yeah and it's surprising but i don't
have a bank account yet
because you're too young
uh i think i can get one but i've never
gone to register okay because you don't
need it right
yeah i'm bankless
the twelve-year-old made four hundred
thousand dollars and he's bankless i
love it has any of the bankers called
you yet do you are the wealth managers
calling you up like yo kid i got some
ideas for you
uh
i've got a few requests and my dm's in
discord but apart from that not really
amazing and then what you talked about
infrastructure what do you think the
opportunity is uh for infrastructure
like you want to build like an exchange
or what do you want to do
so
when i look at nft in the digital art
scene
to me they come in three groups so the
first group is
art that people are willing to spend
loads on so this is like crypto punks
and art blocks these this artwork
outlines your crypto renaissance
the second group is artwork which will
turn into billion dollar brands for
example cool cats broad aids these will
expand into merchandise games and a
whole host of other sexes
and the last group is nfts that are
really cheap but have a lot of utility
so this is
nfts like avatar pictures and skins and
cosmetics in different games and weapons
and i think in this group is where a
billion dollar infrastructure business
lies
i i like that idea can i can i make a
deal with you
uh if you want
if you start a company can i invest uh
sure
all right we'll talk later but if you do
something i'll invest
i don't know if you'll be successful or
not but it sounds like you're smarter
than me so i'm in
all right john joe and john you guys got
any other questions no you're a legend
benjamin thanks for doing this
keep it up
benjamin we're going to bring you back
on this show i feel like you're going to
do other crazy stuff we're going to have
to keep bringing you back are you on
twitter
yeah yeah what's your username
at obi-wan bernini
why why did you pick that name that's an
awesome name you're you look at the
phone pictures all the time
benjamin the photo makes you immediately
if i see that photo on twitter i'm like
this guy's a g he's he's locked and
loaded why'd you pick obi-wan bononi
so uh someone was born i i don't know
why but my family nicknamed me banoni
and then a few years ago my brother came
across the screen name obi-wan banoni
and he told me about it i just adopted
that as my username on every single
platform i go on so in games i'm at
obi-wan benoni and on twitter i'm out
obama so that's why i chose it mandy
that's amazing and uh is your brother
doing nft drops too or is just you
uh my brother's not doing nst however
he's an amazing creator just like me
we've both been coding from a very young
age he's less
he's more shy on social media and these
platforms however he's just he's just as
a good coder as me
i love it i love that you're supporting
your brother too all right last question
i saw somebody asking in the comments
are girls coming after you no do you
have like a whole line of list of of
people who want to be your girlfriend
now
uh
well
the thing about my dms i've closed them
to only people that i follow so i don't
really follow that many oh you're not
even worried about local school you're
like
you're international he's global he's
global
obi wan bononi is absolutely global
gotta close the dms
all right what can we do to help you
right now is there anything that we can
do other than tell people to go follow
you on twitter
um
i think uh you allowing me to come on
this show has just helped me a lot to be
honest oh you listen you have an open
invitation whenever you do anything you
can come on the show people love you we
love you and we're going to uh next time
that we talk you're going to tell me
what company you're going to build i'm
going to invest and then i'm going to go
brag to everyone that i invested in a 12
year old that's smarter than me and my
brothers
sound good
yeah all right buddy thank you so much
what oh by the way hold on i just put uh
in the chat i just put your twitter
account so everyone go follow them but
is there anywhere that we should send
them to see your collection
on openstack or somewhere yeah you could
send them the openc link it's
just search up weird wells and it's the
one with the flashy gif
weird whale sorry i'm gonna do right now
weird whales on openc
yeah i just dropped in the chat for
everyone his link tree
oh jon
we got weird whales i'm gonna put that
in the chat as well
what why did you think of weird whales
why'd you call it that name
so most of the collection i've seen they
have their whatever their nft is and
then adjectives before it so you have
cool cats and they've got quarterly
adjectives and i thought of an adjective
beginning with w and the first one that
came to mind was weird so that's why i
went with it i got it i like it i like
it well guess what you know who else
liked it
the audience because you sold four
hundred thousand dollars
[Laughter]
absolutely legend when's your birthday
by the way when do you turn 13
uh my birthday is on march the 9th all
right so it's coming up here no in a few
months
can we get
can i give you a challenge
uh sure you have 400 000 in sales now
can you get to a million before 13
uh i'm hoping i can alright because then
you could tell your brother that you
were a millionaire before 13 and he was
it
that's an interesting flex
[Laughter]
listen i i i'm too old to try to do that
so you uh you're you're my last hope all
right so a million dollars by the time
you turn 13 or i'm sorry yeah 13 in
march that's the goal
uh you got this man we're cheering you
on everyone make sure you go follow him
on twitter make sure you go check out
openc john drop the link tree in there
uh any last words benjamin
um
thanks for having me on the show
you're a legend man all right we're
definitely gonna bring you back on we'll
talk later but i appreciate you coming
on tell your dad thank you and uh tell
your brother let's go we uh we got two
uh two geniuses you guys are the true
super coders by the way in the us they
say that's a bad thing and in my eyes
that's a good thing so keep it up you're
doing a great job
thank you all right see you later buddy
see you later bye bye
legend dude that kid
electric legend all right that kid is a
star i'm calling it right now book it
record this that kid is going to change
the world and you've met him here first
i'm telling you that kid's changing
welcome what's up guys bang bang it's
your boy pomp thanks so much for
watching the best business show our goal
is to make this the largest most
actionable business show in the world
and to do that we need your help we've
partnered with sofi as our exclusive
sponsor because they have a piece of
software that we think will help you
take the information that we share on a
daily basis and make it actionable we
want every single person to pursue and
achieve financial security and financial
freedom in order to do that you gotta
act and sofi allows you to do it so you
can go to sofi.com pomp today you can
open up an account and when you open up
an account you can invest in all sorts
of different types of assets etfs
individual stocks ipos bitcoin
cryptocurrencies they even have an
automated investing function if you want
to invest sofi can help you they've got
a couple of different offers that you
can benefit from the first open an
invest account and they'll give you up
to a thousand bucks for free kind of a
no-brainer second is if you go on and
you buy one of the cryptocurrencies that
they offer they'll go ahead and they'll
give you ten dollars of bitcoin for free
and third some of you are saying i
already have a brokerage account i
already have an account somewhere else
right now you can get up to five
thousand dollars for transferring your
account that's right so sofi doesn't
care where your current account is but
if you transfer from that place to sofi
they'll pay you up to five thousand
dollars for doing it why wouldn't you do
it it's up to five thousand dollars for
free head on over to sofi.com today to
get started and come back tomorrow and
watch more of the best business show
together we're gonna build the biggest
show in the world
[Music]